Todd McShea from the worldwide leader in
sports joining us here on the program
Todd are you part of the two-hour window
that ESPN's so putting on the air this
weekend I am I am we're excited
so it's the first year since since I was
younger and not even with the SPN that
I've actually been able to get into the
combine and unfortunately I won't be
watching you as much but other than that
it's oh no I appreciate you bringing it
back to me Todd but uh so did you did
you did you run a forty at the
University of Richmond or what no yes I
mean I ran one but it was not certainly
part of any combine and and I didn't run
it very fast I think four four eight
nine somewhere in that range it fixed
195 pounds like I know so what would
Todd make Shay the evaluators say about
Todd make sure the football player what
are they say try hard guy the old thg
the try hard guy the thg doesn't move
real well I'll give you everything in
Scouting fantastic I love it alright
let's so let's let's dive into it right
here
we're where are you on your quarterback
board right now Todd who's number one on
it for you I've got Haskins but I've got
I've got them basically you know one
tick ahead of Cuyler Murray I think it's
really those two to me and I think after
that you've got a bunch of guys that you
you feel good about could develop into a
good backup in the league and maybe a
couple of them that potentially there's
there's some starting ability there to
relax from Missouri
daniel Jones from Duke Ryan Finley who I
think is underrated but doesn't have any
any Wow skills without him coming out of
North Carolina State Derrick Stidham
from Auburn will Grier from West
Virginia so there is depth but to me the
only two guys that have true first-round
grades are Haskins and Murray and
they're both one-year starters asking to
as nearly as mobile as Murray but
there's more of a pure passer and Murray
if you hit on him
you have the right system and utilize
them properly could be an absolute so
then which is the Teamsters an athlete
so which is the teams that dead check
those if boxes Todd well you know you've
got the giant sitting there at six and I
think that that to me would make a lot
of sense for Haskins then you've got
Jacksonville at seven and then after
that you know you have to look at well
Cincinnati finally try to make a move
and make a change or Miami what
direction are they gonna try to go
obviously they need to handle their
quarterback situation as well so those
are those are four or five of the top
teams I think in the first half of the
first round know when you said though of
all the if things that need to be hit
for Murray though you gotta have the
right coach the right offense the right
system the right etc etc would the
jaguars be that team at number seven i
mean let's let's let's see who's
possible here cuz we're assuming let's
just assume nobody trades up in the top
five because they get antsy over Haskins
knowing that the Giants are gonna take
them let's just say that that happens so
that means the teams that will have a
shot at taking Tyler Murray are the
Jaguars the Broncos the Bengals the
Dolphins at thirteen although I hear
that they're tanking for two like
starting now okay what do you think I
mean who are the ones what they ought
right all those box you say if this team
has XY and Z more easier guy which one I
think Jacksonville make sense from from
this standpoint that and I you know with
John de Filippo he can adjust what he
wants to do but you know you have a run
game you know you have a defense and if
you can get back to playing anywhere
near two years ago on the defensive side
now it's bringing someone who can who
can add to the run game and doesn't have
to be throwing the ball thirty times
again so I to me that one would make
sense and you know everyone says well
you know at this place they don't have
an offensive guy that in some places
don't but Bill O'Brien
came from the patriot way and adjusted
his system to Shaun Watson and you know
the from the burbage to the tempo to
play calling and just the different
things that they Watson was doing in
college and having success he's a great
example to me of a guy who halfway
through his coaching career can say you
know what we've got to swap out what we
did and we've got to do it to make sure
our quarterback is comfortable and I
think we're starting to see the league
transition more as the quarterback and
really the college game starts to
trickle up from the college level to the
NFL well in your mock draft Todd McShea
here in the Rich Eisen show from or
right around the Superbowl time your
second mock draft has Jacksonville and
the Broncos and the Bengals all passing
on Murray only to have the Dolphins go
and take him why do you and and and put
that together with the notion again that
it's crazy to start tanking for a player
that's coming out but what do you what
are you put together there Todd you know
I first of all I don't think he makes
this decision Kyler Murray to to walk
away from the four point six six million
dollars with the Oakland A's and come to
the NFL if he didn't get I don't want to
say occurrence but I think you know
strong input that there are teams in the
first round of water now every team I
talked to and I don't talk to teams
really that that have quarterbacks
already because they they typically give
an honest opinion everyone's ago I be
nervous with Murray I do
nervous because of the size nervous
because really the right system forum
nervous because if things don't go well
early in his career is he gonna pick up
and head over to play baseball and not
even be with us anymore so are we
getting the full five years if we use a
first-round pick on so there there are
risk involved but to me this guy is he's
a special player at the most important
position and what's the difference
between an inch at this point I mean and
everyone says oh he's not sick we build
and he doesn't have to wide frame it
listen he stood next to him multiple
times he's he's thicker than people
seemed to think he is small he is going
to come in around
five nine but we've seen we've seen guys
that 510 and a half to it why can't five
nine five nine and a half to it and
again in the last ten years we've seen
quarterbacks were six foot and shorter
have a few a lower percentage of balls
batted down than guys that are six one
and taller we've seen the game change
completely with quarterbacks running
more the most in terms of the last ten
years that the quarterbacks have ever
run or have run was this past season by
a large amount and it keeps going up
every year and quarterbacks are throwing
the ball at a higher percentage outside
of the pocket than ever before
compared to inside the pocket so again
the game is changing and it fits
it's like Tyler Murray now and you don't
have to be that sixth floor pocket
passer to have successfully now we're
talking Todd about Zion Williamson maybe
sitting out the entire year
to save himself for the college
basketball draft even though we have not
heard from him and Coach K says he wants
to play but there's so many people that
read stuff in to what Sion is thinking
and that may absolutely be the case with
Carla Murray and the question I'm about
to ask what would the evaluation
community think if Murray refused to be
measured at the combine Todd it would be
frustration but I think you know just to
me you're either in or you're out on the
guy you know if you stand next to him
you can get a gauge of how tall he is
and then that stood next to him as I
said it a few times and I'm guessing
he's in that five nine range and if he's
five nine and a half what does it matter
no I don't think he's gonna refuse to I
don't expect that at all I haven't heard
that from anybody but um but it you know
things are changing do it with with
players and and their rights and I think
we're starting to see more and more
players not playing in the ball game to
protect themselves more and more guys
opting out of you know growing at the
combine or doing different things so
nothing will surprise me but I think if
everyone else is doing it and it's not
going to it really isn't going to hurt
you unless you know for a fact that
you're like five seven and change and
then then there's a
certainly you start to look at it and I
would have a little bit more concern but
if you know you're in that five nine
range what do you hide I know the eye
and the sky doesn't lie and nor does a
tape measure you know and if if if if he
is who he is and we've interviewed him a
couple times one time in person at the
Super Bowl when he had not yet gotten
the green light to announce his decision
and it was really awkward I'll be very
honest with you no it was really it was
really awkward but you know I mean he is
who he is and it doesn't matter how tall
he is he's still gonna come kick your
ass so I would be surprised if he
doesn't if he turns down the measurement
portion to combine which by the way the
combine was created exactly for that not
the rest of this stuff I think people
have a little bit of the wrong
impression when it comes to Tyler he's a
quiet guy he is really the opposite of
Baker Mayfield in terms of leadership
and what he brings from an energy
standpoint rah rah and all that stuff
but what he is is he's he's a competitor
he's poised and I think the biggest
thing that people don't realize because
he was walking back and forth him
because he had all those bolts you know
the multiple awkward interviews at the
Super Bowl he loves football and it
really from what I am told from people
then who are close to him it's always
been his passion he just had a really
tough decision to make because you're
you got four point six six million
guaranteed there he had to work out all
the logistics in terms of it you know
switching an agent and figuring out is
he going to be a first-round pick or is
he coming to the NFL to be a third-round
pick and not not getting to guaranteed
money and is he making a bad investment
his future and he's a young guy he's you
know that's a lot to take in
he should never have gone to the
Superbowl and done those interviews he
had not made his decision yet but you
know that's behind him and it's to me as
long as I know that he loves the game
and he's in it for the long haul then it
becomes about the football player and
and we can figure out the rest of the
stuff but that would be the only thing
that scares me and it seems from all my
information so far that it's not the
issue and that he's going all in on this
Todd
here in the Rich Eisen show deepest
position at the combine is what
defensive line what would you say
yeah defensive line so why I mean it's
crazy i it's like every time i pop in
tape these days and and walk to another
defensive line learn what I'm giving a
first second or third round great I mean
you got a defensive end you get Nick
dosa from out of state were sound Gary
Michigan Montez sweat Mississippi State
Quillin thorough from Clemson Brian
burns from Florida State all of those
guys could be first-round picks and then
defensive tackles even deeper and I
won't list off all the names I'm just
looking at my list right now starting
with Quinn and Williams who I think is
gonna be second or third overall pick
coming out of Alabama I've got 10 guys
defensive tackle along in the top 100
and six of them in the top 40 and then
that's not even cluding guys like Josh
Allen from Kentucky who was an edge
rusher at the Hyppolite for Florida
another address to be first-round pick
so it's to me in 20 years of doing this
this is a deepest group of defensive
tackles / edge defenders that I've ever
evaluated it's deep man I mean we could
have the first five draft choices not be
a ball carrier of any sort of ball a
quarterback or wide receiver or a
running back I don't recall something
like that that's going to be quite
something
and everyone in the TV business is kind
of frustrated although that you know
Cuyler Murray added to some of the drama
of this year there this year's class but
to me if you if you really love football
you really watch the game right now
outside of quarterback I think finding
pass rushers is the most important part
of evaluating and the most important
position on the field on the field I
mean you got to get to these
quarterbacks and it used to just be a
dressers but you look at it Aaron
Donald's of the world there's not
there's only one of them but a guy like
Aaron Donald shows you if you can get
there from the inside it's even quicker
to get to the quarterback and you can
cause even more disruption so well some
people are frustrated with the lack of
fake name offensive skill guys this year
I think it's an awesome draft okay
couple quick
for your table before I send John unto
your rest of your Monday the runningback
that could be the chimera of the group
the guy who is the third fourth rounder
that could come out of nowhere be
everybody's fantasy football darling and
make free agent running backs less
prominent give me one of those rookies
Darryl Henderson from Memphis is an
intriguing player could be a third-round
pick Rodney
Anderson from Oklahoma will fall because
he's coming off the injury this past
year but if he gets healthy and right he
was a I think a late first early
second-round prospect and another guy
Memphis has two players and this is
later rounds I'm talking like fourth
fifth round Toni Pollard is a former
receiver moved into running back who can
kind of do both and have some juice
those are three times I think we're
gonna wind up being value picks at the
the running back position yeah and we'll
see them on Friday and then obviously
the wide outs on on Saturday with the
defensive backs on Monday and last one
for you Todd breakdown the fastest one
who's gonna be the one that jumps off
the screen when they're samel cammed
over yours truly from why Ron who's the
fastest one who can break it what do you
got for me I'm told Nicole Hardman from
Georgia is going to be one of those guys
you know in the 4-3 is potentially
McLaurin the the wide receiver from Ohio
State was the fastest guy with pads on
it at the Senior Bowl and then at the
cornerback position who is I just
watched I was just watching the corner
find his name now but there's that guy
who's kind of a off the radar type of
guy that that could run in the in the
four threes is well I don't know that
we're gonna see another record this year
but um I think there's should be some
four threes for you Miss Moore does
Murray break for fourth you think look
he's gonna run if he does I say I say
yes I say it'll be close but I say yes
okay time I look forward to seeing Indy
thanks for the call really appreciate it
you got at the top McShea at McShea 13
on twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience